have you seen this dog a family reeling
after their house was broken into
thousands of dollars worth of items
stolen and their beloved puppy gone
police currently on the hunt for who
could have done this Madison Kimbrough
spoke to the family and has their story
it's been almost a week since the Gonda
family had their house broken into and
now with the help from police and video
footage the hope is that their missing
puppy will be brought home safely we
just got the dog you know we haven't
even gave them a name yet everything is
gone a family playing for the Public's
help after their house was ransacked and
their new puppy stolen this happening
last Wednesday when Eric's roommate came
home to find the place in shambles my
room torn up
like everything from the closet to our
drawers everything was ramp Shack they
took a lot of my memorabiliers you know
they took about five thousand dollars in
cash that I was saving to go on a
vacation trip the whole burglary caught
on camera from a neighbor's house across
the street as the culprits broke into
the ganda's home through their side
window the video footage also showing
they spent a decent amount of time
inside before taking off we saw the bag
you know as they were running out and
you could see as they got to the car the
bag was moving we also have another dog
in there was dramatized because they I
think they used one of our broomsticks
to hit him Eric's wife Andrea fearful
for what's next saying that being at
home just doesn't feel safe anymore
because I had to lock my bedroom door
because
I don't know if they're gonna come back
I don't know why they just picked us or
targeted us I'm not gonna
let nobody run me out of my house and
Metro Police telling eight news now that
the incident is currently an ongoing
investigation and if you know anything
that may help police your urge to call
Crime Stoppers that number is on your
screen in Spring Valley Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now